et
[Musique]
c'était il y à très très très longtemps
en ce temps là il y avait le ciel au
milieu du ciel il y avait la terre et
sur la terre il n'y avait rien ou
presque rien
la population de la terre compter
quelques bestioles pas très réussis
comme le gorille but
le lapin poisson et le minet quand amp
espèces qui étaient en voie de
disparition rapide plus certaines
insectes dunois de gégène et qu'ils
n'avaient pas l'intention de disparaître
du tout comme nous le verrons paradis à
gauche du ciel il y avait des shadoks et
la fusée shadoks à droite du ciel il y
avait les jbe et la fusée jpy comme nos
téléspectateurs le savent
l'egypte y avait un petit chapeau sur la
tête et c'était là le secret de leur
intelligence quand aj by réfléchissait à
quelque chose d'un peu compliqué hop il
mettait ça dans son chapeau sa passe est
automatiquement dans les autres chapeaux
et tous les gimmicks mettait à
réfléchirons ensemble sans qu'on ait
besoin de leur explique pour la
nourriture
il n'avait pas de problème non plus il y
avait des gibiers a peint des gibiers à
l'est et des gibiers un fromage
c'est dire que pour aller sur une
planète même lointaine l'egypte y
n'avait pas besoin d'en pour dire autre
chose que leur chapeau et tout ce
monde-là voulait aller sur la terre
réussiront ils à partie arriveront-ils
même sur la terre que sont ils devenus
aujourd'hui
[Musique]